Fucking
Der streamende haas genau den haben wir gestern geguckt
Genshin impact
Na ja ganz ehrlich so ein riesen ding was die da drauf gerade machen verstehe ich nicht aber ok
So und leute was geht irgendwas spannendes passiert
habe ich irgendwas verpasst war irgendwas außer die üblichen sachen dass die bar nicht pünktlich ist
und solche geschichten war irgendwas spannendes
ich muss morgen wieder nach frankfurt fahren ich habe keinen bock schon wieder 50 tapps offen
was der fuck das sind 50 tapps da habe ich auch mehr tapps und in der vm habe ich noch mal tapps
aber ich mein ernsthaft ram ist dafür da um benutzt zu werden guck mal warum habe ich denn
sonst 32 gigabyte ram wenn ich es nicht verwende 11 gigabyte sind da voll und davon sind nur
gigabyte oder so das ist doch nix gigabyte browser tapps null ist doch nix da geht was
mit programmieren anfangen was hältst du für den c plus das ist die bait die frage oder das ist das
gigabyte um mich zum c++ rant zu g baiten oder willst du wirklich wissen also also c++ ist
definitiv keine gute einstiegssprache ich die frage war g bait aber für alle also c++ ist
glaube ich die schlechteste einsteigersprache die man sich so vorstellen kann und das schlimme
ist c++ ist eine schlechte einsteigersprache und c++ ist auch eine schlechte fortgeschrittenen
sprache und auch eine schlechte sprache c++ ist eigentlich immer schlecht außer dort wo es keine
alternativen zugibt und dann ist c++ auch schlecht aber man kommt nicht drumherum ja sehe ich genauso
go geht meinetwegen auch noch wenn es unbedingt so was sein soll ja aber ich persönlich bin für
javascript wer heute anfängt weil dazu brauchst du in editor und browser und ganz loslegen und
du lernst nebenbei noch etwas html und css das ist ja was wo heutzutage so bisschen frontend
da kommt eigentlich keiner dran vorbei zu unkomplex wie komplex was ist nicht so sehr an der sprache
außer c++ sondern was du damit programmierst sagt es mal in dem machine learning projekt auf
github dass sie zu wenig komplex sind außerdem hat pysons saumäßig viele funktionen pysons schön
zu lesen aber ich würde nicht sagen dass es nicht komplex ist du kannst da ganz viel abgedrehten
sachen drin machen von list komprensions oder wie das heißt mittlerweile sogar type annotations
und alles will da gibt es viel zu lernen ja ja ist so ich glaube mit sampler lernst du
heutzutage auch nicht mal wirklich wie ein pc funktioniert du lernst vielleicht ein bisschen
was ja aber ich meine es ist halt immer noch ganz normales windows user mode also sprich
was da wie wo genau passiert du lernst natürlich was über cpu instruktion schon klar du lernst
zum beispiel auch was für abgedrehten scheiß moderne cpus können wo man sich denkt was so
was ist ein befehl von der cpu da macht die dann ziegenkäse mit der pizza ja pizza würde
ich jetzt auch eine futtern was ist denn malbolge kann man danach googeln nicht dass das jetzt
wieder irgendwie der chain law mit neuem account ist oder so ist eine gemeinfrei esoterische
programmiersprache ok ja ob wir es sieht aus wie irgendwas verschlüsselt und aus versehen
auf standard out gepiped malbolge oder so vba ja da kommst den office ja heute immer
noch nicht so richtig dran vorbei oder gibt es da mittlerweile was neues dankeschön zwei
monate massive subscription hier warum hört man den sound nicht lull es war einfach zu
langsam oder es dauert wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ich wollte es eigentlich schon vor
zwei wochen machen ich bin aber gerade nicht so in video stimmung ich mach wahrscheinlich
vorher noch ein anderes video als mir danach ist ich muss da immer in der richtigen recording
stimmung sein ich muss mal ganz kurz in den fiat champ reingucken da habe ich nämlich
eben einem geschrieben dass er mal was ausprobieren soll ich will mal kurz gucken ob er das ausprobiert
hat also nicht ausprobiert ok weil weil leute leute kakona der fiat champ hat jetzt truck
support ram track so support hell yeah ram track truck nicht track endlich keine kortkamp
heute net heute habe ich keinen bock muss man dazu eigentlich early access geordert haben
oder kann das kann man das wenn man das bestellt hat heute schon spielen still and his champ
ich weiß nicht wer was das für einen hersteller ist aber ich würde mir also ich kaufe mir
nie fertige pcs aber 40 90 gibt es auch bestimmt zu kaufen oder 40 90 sind halt so teuer ich
glaube nicht dass die mittlerweile schon alle ausverkauft sind so lieferbar
halt abartig teuer der shit ne alter was das denn hier ach komplett system ok ok ok ok
wv 5 wv 5 ist ganz ok wv 20 42 ist das was so gesagt hat wv 5 haben sie ja aufgehört
zu supporten als es ganz ok war das spiel ist das hat angefangen mit dem pacific update
dass es ganz gut ist und dann haben sie noch machen wir jetzt nicht wir machen es bf 20
42 und da verkacken wir alles ja prinzipiell schon aber ich habe es nicht gespielt und
die sache ist die ich habe eigentlich gar keinen bock mehr auf overwatch mir das wieder
zu geben ja wie sieht es aus overwatch glaube ich glaube du hast auch keinen bock oder nee
ich weiß nicht dass mir das handling von blizzard mit overwatch eins nicht gefallen
und das hat mich so so abgeschreckt nur noch am ende des games weiß nicht ich habe kaum
was andere so viel gespielt die letzten jahre über wie overwatch also am stück aber weiß
ich das irgendwie als blizzard geschafft das kann man auf das game ab
ist ein 6000 9006 hat k und 38 gut kombiniert was weiß ich keine ahnung ich kenne mich
bei aktueller desktop hardware nicht aus ich kenne mich nur aus wenn ich was kaufen
will und das ist erst im december soweit es sieht aber jetzt erst einmal gar nicht so
verkehrt aus das ist ja so ein ja soll man so oberes oberes mittelklasse ding hier mit
mit einer mittelklasse grafikkarte warum nicht ja kann schon sein dass das gut funktioniert
ich denke sie das war nicht so verkehrt aus und sie auch schon bis sie älter das teil
ja mal gucken wie lang bettgetheim in einer stunde 15 leute kein only fans fans lie habe
ich doch schon öfters gesagt wenn überhaupt dann fans lie selbes game mit erweiterung
ja nur dass sie 2 cp rausgeschmissen haben gut warst du recht 2 cp war der größte kackenmodus
überhaupt gestern kam anscheid für ach haben die jetzt die ganze anscheid collection irgendwie
auf dem pc rausgebracht das spiele ich auch noch mal das spiele ich auch nicht on stream
aber da hätte ich echt mal wieder bock drauf die spiele waren richtig gut das war so richtig
ja wie nennt man das so rund um also die story war ok die sprüche waren ok die das gameplay
war richtig gut die animationen waren eines der besten die die ich bis dahin je gesehen
hatte ja anscheidet war wirklich in der serie da kann ich wirklich sagen die habe ich gern
gespielt die kann ich eigentlich auch immer mal wieder spielen
trumpscript trumpscript das ist schon wieder eingestellt worden 2018 gibt es da ein example
ach so verstehe das ist sowas sowas wie chef plus für plus für trump reden anscheid
overwatch 3 die hatten ja schon irgendwie jetzt drei jahre verspätung oder so mit overwatch
2 das wird nix mit nächstem jahr nächstes jahr höchstens half life 3 sammelt windows
elf persönliche daten microsoft sagt nee oder sagen sie überhaupt nee aber ich würde
eher sagen ja microsoft hat wahrscheinlich einfach umdefiniert was persönliche daten
sind und kann jetzt behaupten sie sammeln keine persönlichen daten es ist alle alles
eine frage des scopes das wissen wir und wenn die gesagt haben eure persönliche daten sind
einfach keine persönlichen daten mehr dann sammeln sie keine persönlichen daten kennst
du den neuen samsung odyssey arg ich habe keine ahnung was das ist leute ihr fragt mich
heute so viel zeug ich habe keinen plan was es ist ach das doch das habe ich gesehen das
habe ich letztens irgendwo news gesehen das ist ja ja doch das habe ich gesehen anfangen
ist anfangen des jahres oder so na ja 55 zoll kopf ich wusste nicht wie das ding heißt
doch das habe ich gesehen danke für die ganzen subs leute ich hab es irgendwie schon wieder
übersehen pepega style was hältst du von dem naja ganz schön teuer auf der anderen
seite 55 zoll und was haben wir sonst noch ich meine das ding ist ungefähr so groß wie
mein fernseher überleg grad was habe ich denn für ein fernseher habe ich 60 zoll weiß
kein genau wilder igel dange schön 100 milliarden bits massive was hatten der für für wiederholrate
und wiederhole hier meine sind tft am mannens halt immer noch so 165 herz das wäre mir
zu wenig unter 240 ihr kennt mich ich abgrade wenn ich hardware upgrade dann muss jedes einzelne
stadt eigentlich besser gleich dem alten sein sonst abgrade ich nicht also mein neuer rechner
braucht mindestens 32 g ram besser 64 mal neuer monitor braucht mindestens 240 herz besser
320 360 sind so mittlerweile schon oder das auge sieht nur 12 fps ja ja ich weiß ich
weiß mit 224 das ist allgemein bekannt leute das ist der sinnloseste slider den ich je
gesehen habe samsung was ist der sinn von diesem slider chat wer ist hrq genug und kann
mir erklären was die samsung leute sich gedacht haben mit diesem slider normalerweise kann
man das leiden dann kommen da noch ein bisschen mehr dinger aber so hätte man einfach ganz
normales so zu lassen können ohne irgendwas und das hätte keinen gestört ach fürs handy
das ist quasi responsive und vergessen auf dem desktop auszumachen viele möglichen viele
möglichkeiten auf nur einem display multiview ja gut mit 55 zoll kann es natürlich quasi
so tun als hätte drei bildschirme das ist klar ja oben guckte irgendwelche e-sport dinger
was ist das keine ahnung wall on one starcraft großartig fällt mir halbwegs verbreitetes
wall on one jetzt eigentlich gar nicht mehr ein mein quake wird es ja wohl kaum sein
das meisten sachen sind doch eigentlich team games mittlerweile zs ist ein team game schach
das sieht sehr nach schach aus zs ist ein team game dota lol fifa ja vielleicht pupke
auch teams fortnight bestimmt fortnight messer relaxing music ja was soll ich davon halten
ganz ehrlich ich bräuchte nett macht man würde man ganz ins schreibtisch quasi noch
voller machen der würde wahrscheinlich links und rechts an fast fast ein stückchen über
stehen und ich brauche keine drei bildschirme und auch kein so grob also für das für das
geld ganz ehrlich für das geld würde ich mir lieber einen neuen rechner kaufen und
noch ein bisschen was drauf legen dann reicht es auf eine 40 90 ne also es spricht mich
jetzt persönlich nicht so an ein spiel der sinne ein bisschen marketing bullshit muss
natürlich sein die wollen den kram ja verkaufen eclipser achter hat sogar mb light auf dem
rückseite mein fernseher hat auch mb light ohne dass ich ohne dass ich einen hätte mit
mb light also ich habe hinten so eine led so led leisten dran die fake mb light machen
das richtig gut der sennheiser mikrofon oder sah so aus wegen was gescheit soll man
schnell den chat hier skippen gibt's denn kohann der krieger anschartet lp habe ich
nie geguckt puzzle weis der langische für den zapp bei uns ist das root laufwerk bei
einem physischen dell server folge laufen ich konnte mich aber nicht auf das eitrack
verbinden weil unsicht der dia war ab jetzt geblockt sind und das eitrack zahlt für tja
shit happens macht in den linux vm und installier irgendwas altes dann easy wobei vms war ja
auch geblockt sind hilft bloß noch ssh login auf dem eitrack geht ja meistens auch kannst
du das eitrack so was möchte ich auch ja ich kann es nehmen aber das gibt es nicht mehr
du musst nach aktuellen alternativen gucken die gibt es aber dream screen ist das teil
was ich mir gekauft habe und nicht bei telekohl kraft telekohl kraft das hört sich an wie
so ein kleiner kleiner laden auf der hauptstraße bei uns ja wo gehen wir hin zum telekohl
kraft ja so ein teil hier sitz bei das cock da aber dann schönes video auf telekohl kraft
ist immer noch am start schieb es geben youtube ich zeig es euch mal kurz wie das ausschaut
also wie gesagt dass ich finde das wirklich top mit sicherheit mit sicherheit alter ist
das ein dumm schmetzer wieder meine güte alter ich bin fast schon geneigt da kurz durch
zu skippen
wir gucken das nicht wir gucken das nicht ich skippe da nur mal kurz durch ich will wissen
was? was? was haben die? was haben die? will der mich verarschen? die haben fast nix gemacht
die maps sehen immer noch aus wie der zerpraktikant in der mittagspause erstellt hat die haben
einfach paar kisten auf 2 auf 2 von den maps es gibt kaum maps die auf den maps ist kaum
was drauf die meisten leute wollten ja auch nie specialist haben ich fand die idee gar
nicht so verkehrt alter ne das gucken wir jetzt nicht meine güte what the fuck
ich kann sich aussprechen aber dankeschön für den sub
high iq zeichen
ja das ist prinzip alles das kann ja alles sein ich habe übrigens eine anfrage bekommen
ob eine firma mir einen moment das gucken wir uns gleich mal zusammen an einen gaming tisch
zuschicken kann den gucken wir uns gleich mal an
wir haben eine deutsche domain aber er schreibt auf englisch hä? gaming tisch ich frag mich
was an einem gaming tisch gaming sein soll vielleicht hat der rgb oder so gucken wir
uns gleich mal an was die da wollen von mir du zockst mittlerweile auf 120z das wäre mir
viel zu groß ich habe jetzt hier eine 240hz was ist denn das für einer 24 zoll oder so
bangq ne 27 zoll ja so einer was ist das für einer 25 zoll wahrscheinlich ist das hier
ja 24,5 zoll das reicht mir voll und ganz ich habe neben dran noch einen bildschirm
stehen habe ich die vorschau und so alles das wäre mir viel viel zu groß aber bestimmt
gewöhnungs sache und wahrscheinlich wenn man sich an gewöhnt hat will man da nichts
anderes mehr achso ambilight produkt sekunde ups wollte ich wollte ich ja zeigen hier ambilight
da hat mich das levelcap gebadet dreamscreen hier ist das ding ja hier sieht man es eigentlich
ganz gut so sieht es dann aus richtig coole geschichte was er daneben hängen hat habe
ich keine ahnung lautsprecher wahrscheinlich ist wirklich cool es passt sich auch wirklich
gut dem farbspektrum wirklich nice also kann man nichts sagen ist top also das hat sich
wirklich gelohnt als teil hinten dran die sache ist nur die aktuell gibt es kein dreamscreen
mehr es gibt aber konkurrenzprodukte da kann ich dir aber nichts empfehlen weil ich die
nicht habe ja aber das wirklich poc hoge was macht das surface oder heißt jetzt archface
leute ich habe es noch nicht mal installiert ich wollte da heute vormittag anfangen und
dann ist mir aufgefallen ich muss noch irgend so eine komische liste in confluence ausfüllen
und wenn man tabellen in confluence bearbeitet hat weiß wie geil das ist gachi bus beste
da geht mir richtig einer bei ab wenn ich tabellen in confluence bearbeiten muss ja
ich muss mal gucken nach alternativen es gibt ja dreamscreen alternativen ok nice wir sind
durch jo was macht der zuck denn schon wieder geld ausgeben ins meta wird ja wir wissen
ja die entwickler finden das meta selbst bescheuert aber sie müssen es lieben um es verkaufen
zu können oder was auch immer der manager da schreibt 240 hertz oled das ist was das
würde ich mir auch geben das browser wie stimmt wir müssen noch das browser video
fertig gucken wo sind wir überhaupt stehen geblieben das da tatsächlich wir haben noch
viertel stunde viertel stunde von dem konferenztalk müssen wir noch fertig gucken jetzt hier
sind wir irgendwo stehen geblieben ne leute wo sind wir stehen geblieben nojs nojs sind
wir stehen geblieben monka es alter javascript auf dem server wir gucken das wir gucken
das gleich fertig ja komm wir haben noch eine stunde zeit wir werden in der stunde die viertel
stunde werden wir schaffen die musik zu leise
so irgendwas irgendwas war doch vorhin noch wo ich gesagt habe ich zeig es euch gleich
ach so ja ich habe eine anfrage bekommen ob ich einen gaming ein gaming desk sponsoring
möchte so also ob ich einen gaming tisch haben möchte und wieder in sponsoren machen
wie heißt das ding flexi spot e7 so mal gucken ob das was taucht bevor ich da irgendwie youtube
sellout mache flexi spot gaming tisch elektrisch verstellbares tischgestell hat er lampen da
unten oder was ist da los das sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie ein gaming tisch das ist ein
ganz normales ganz normales tischgestell was hat das jetzt mit gaming zu tun wahrscheinlich
verkauft moment segunde monka es vielleicht verkaufen die einfach ihr ganz normales ganz
normales gestell als gaming desk jetzt das ganz normaler tisch sieht mehr oder weniger
so aus wie den tisch den ich habe ich habe hier so einen tisch also einen höhenverstellbaren
tisch mit der alten platte die platte habe ich schon lang die hatte ich sogar früher
noch im kinderzimmer unten hier beim opa im kinderzimmer so alt ist die tischplatte
schon am tischplatte gehen auch nicht kaputt die spiel ist 30 jahre alt oder so die tischplatte
kannst du einen 65 zoll tv empfehlen wie gesagt ich kann euch prinzipiell eigentlich so gut
wie nie was empfehlen was hart für angeht außer ich habe es mir selbst gerade gekauft
dann weiß ich immer bescheid ansonsten nicht ok es ist halt ein tisch es ist ein tisch
mit höhenverstellbaren gestell und eine webseite wo man durchaus aber wie sie größere photos
hätte machen können warum nicht ja warum nicht ein bisschen praktischere verstellungs
ding als meins meins ist so ein teil das muss ich das habe ich hinten im schreibtisch liegen
aber ansonsten macht es doch einen ganz guten eindruck maximum gewischt gewischt ja warum
nicht led touchscreen tastatur muss das wirklich sein das ist das erste was kaputt geht macht
einfach buttons so richtig echte buttons zum draufklicken und kein touchpad einfach buttons
so knöpfe wisst ihr so oldschool knöpfe wo du wo drauf drückst dann geht so ein stück
runter und drückt dann irgendwo drauf und dann aber das ist out der sieht eher nach
gaming aus mit rgb was sind das da für futuristische die seite ist ja kommt drauf an also wenn ich
mir mit denen einig werde was sponsoring ja vergütung angeht dann könnte ich mir das
tatsächlich vorstellen einfach nur um des tisches willen werde ich das nicht machen
weil ich habe einen höhenverstellbaren schreibtisch das kostet das irgendwie 400 euro oder so
also ich habe ja schon höhenverstellbaren schreibtisch also für mich ist es ziemlich
ja aufwand dann müsste ich ja alles hier runter räumen austauschen die tischplatte woanders
dran machen es sei denn ich kriege die mit tischplatte geliefert also quasi alles abräumen
ab machen neu für habe ich überhaupt das ist wieder die sache von drei vier stunden
bis das alles wieder steht so wie es sein soll also das müssen wir schon bezahlen einfach
nur des tisches willens mache ich das nicht wie bei einen selbst von ja meiner ist halb
selbst gebaute selbst an dem den gar nichts das einzige was ich an dem hier selbst gemacht
habe ist ich habe die tischplatte festgeschraubt beim akkuschrauber die also ich habe ich habe
das so gemacht ich dachte mir ich bin feifett ich habe das neue gestell unter den alten
tisch gefahren habe das gestell an dem tisch fest geakkuschrauber und dann die und dann
die beine vom alten tisch abgedreht ich habe quasi hotswap gemacht hotswap tischplatte
ja das habe ich auch gesehen das war allerdings eine blöde idee weil das glaube ich anderweitig
viel einfacher gewesen wäre aber hotswap tischplatte hat funktioniert so können wir
nicht irgendwas kleines noch gucken bevor wir das das lange wobei das lange video ist
auch nicht mehr so lang kann man irgendwas kleines gucken top 10 wishel studio code extensions
you need to try ok das müssen wir uns mal wirklich in ruhe angucken das habe ich nicht
gesehen und ks ne das will ich nämlich nicht angucken was haben wir sonst noch watts in
my 10 inch home server ok das geht plus 630 minuten und die die racks von anderen leute
gucke ich mir ja prinzipiell gerne an schau wir gucken uns das vorher mal an sechs minuten
da gucken wir den rest vom konferenztag so dass wenn 22 uhr fertig sind ich platten hotswap
ja so sieht es aus so was hat er dann am start
ja was ist da drinnen ich würde sagen wenn es nicht so spiegeln wird könnte man auch
was erkennen ich würde sagen zwei raspberry pies sind da drinnen
schwer zu sagen irgendein mini patch panel irgendwas mit sfp ports oder sfp plus ports
hinter unten wahrscheinlich die rückseite von einem nuk oder was meint ihr
von wem ist das gesponsert
der cpu hersteller ich habe erst gedacht was auch immer ich habe ich noch nie gesehen
ich persönlich bin auch keystone fan aber wenn man so ein fest installiertes patch
panel hat und überall aj 45 stecker haben will und so ein kleines panel ja das hat man
auch mal relativ schnell drauf gemacht ja also keystone sachen haben halt den vorteil du
kannst mehr du kannst mehrere anschlüsse dran machen so hast du einen patch panel aj
45 anschlüsse fertig hast du so eine keystone leiste kannst du da alles mögliche rein machen
die gibt sogar für usb für aj 45 als für glasfaser ports alles mögliche
was ist chat was habe ich wieder übersehen sieht nach einem qnap aus aha sehen wir gleich
ich hätte ich hätte eher gedacht dass es das ist ein nuk ist da hinten dran aber
es ist ein keystone einfach das ding wo man anschlüsse rein machen warte mal ein
moment keystone panel so ein teil guck da sind so löcher drinne da kannst du dann verschiedene
verschiedene module rein machen kannst du verschiedene module reinklipsen ja keystone
usb zum beispiel guck dann bekommst du so sachen so klipse mit usb oder keystone aj 45 dann
bekommst du so dinger mit aj 45 ports oder keystone mit nee nicht ihr führt nicht ich
darf nicht sfp suchen ich muss lc oder nee wie heißt das ding lc sc lc lc stecker suche
gibt es alles mögliche gibt es alle möglichen module da bist du halt bisschen flexibler
was mit was dein patch panel angeht und die ganz die gleichen dinger auch in so einer
dose verwenden finde ich persönlich ganz praktisch ja gibt es hdmi weiterleitung komische
sattkabel geschichten gibt es gibt es viele varianten von mit mit keystone jacks hauptsächlich
natürlich netzwerk graben ein keystone mit einem charging okay das habe ich so auch
noch nicht gesehen ja aber ich finde es angenehmer ja aber ganz im ernst wenn er hier nur netzwerkkabel
drinne braucht kann man doch kann man doch gerade bei solchen distanzen hier gut wer
weiß nicht wo es dann dahinten hingeht also schon was von stalker gamma gehört ist das
das neue stalker gar nicht eine weile nichts mehr von gehört ich wusste dass es in der
entwicklung ist was da grad läuft kein plan okay es ist für wifi and router so they come
in and they go into a router i don't have the plugs right now qnap qnap ist das ist das
ein q ist das ein qnap switch leute was er da hat weil für den nass ist es auf jeden
fall zu klein das ist ein qnap switch die machen hier auch switche ich finde die ports
sind etwas wie soll ich sagen etwas komisch angeordnet okay vielleicht sind das hier module
auf der backplane die die austauschen können dass die die switche einfach in verschiedenen
konfigurationen liefern können das hier ist ein modul das ist wahrscheinlich ein 10 gigabit
modul sfp plus aj 45 10 g sfp plus aj 45 10 g und das hier wahrscheinlich ein achter
modul 1 g sein das ist wahrscheinlich der management port dann macht es wieder sinn
aber trotzdem irgendwie sieht es komisch von der anordnung aus
für future use
du verbaust nur uniper uniper habe ich lange nichts mein klar die gibt es noch habe ich
lange nichts mehr von gehört also ist wirklich so so ziemlich ruhig drum geworden oder also
ich habe bei mir zum größten teil mikrotik einfach als preisleistungsmäßig absolut
massive es wurde schon nie wir nehmen gucken wir gleich kommt wir gucken gleich den rest
hast nichts verpasst community erweiterung für stalker ist nicht schlecht das sieht man
mal was modding was modding ausmacht und das halt eben die hersteller aus solchen gründen
ja auch keine mods mehr wollen also mein mein mein netzwerk daheim besteht zum größten
teil aus mikrotik ein ubiquity switch allerdings kann unify switch sondern h h switch schwer
auszusprechen x xg 16 es es 16 xg oder sowas 10 gigabit switch mikrotik router mikrotik
switch und mittlerweile auch ordentliche access points kein unify zeug mehr ja das zeug läuft
alles also gerade im heimbereich ganz im ernst ich glaube da gibt es kaum was was nicht läuft
da läuft sogar 5 euro tp link switch klar je nachdem was du machst was du an features
haben willst
aber wirklich netzwerkequipment kaputt gegangen daheim ist mir glaube ich noch nie
ich glaube mir ist noch nie wirklich ich hatte noch nie probleme mit netzwerkequipment
so dass ich im heimbereich da irgendwie probleme bekommen hätte also
ne cisco meraki braucht auch gebraucht für viele features cloud unterstützung oder war
das nicht so deswegen habe ich gesagt kommt mir nicht ins haus
da brauchst du beispielsweise da braucht es dir doch für dynamische wlan passwörter
pro gerät brauchst du auch eine cloud lizenz oder sowas war doch müll wollte ich nicht
deswegen habe ich jetzt ruckus access points
ja das stimmt da sieht man dass es gut dass es gut laufen kann aber viele hersteller machen
halt dicht guck mal es welche spiele mit mod support gibt es denn noch die meisten
triple a games die rauskommen sind komplett mod frei noch nicht mal irgendwelche kleinen
sachen da wird gar nichts gemodet
so mal gucken was er noch im rack drinne hat
ja auch jetzt zeig mal was
ok
dachte ich mir
ne ich denke 14 gigabit ports
ach guck mal es ist gar kein raspberry pi
das aber irgendwie sowas im raspberry pi formfaktor
was gachi bus time oder was ist jetzt los
einfach das backdoor
das ist gut da habe ich ja schon mal bei einer sache das da unten ist ein nuk sage ich euch
jetzt schon
sieht bisschen so aus
ok zeig doch mal was
ich weiß es wäre ganz spannend wenn man das vielleicht auch mal von der anderen seite
sieht
ne das hat hinten eine wand da sieht man gar nichts
ja das ist bestimmt eine nuke
finde es eine gute idee sich die planten selbst auszudrucken
ne ja für sowas hat man eigentlich ein patchpedal
also man geht ja so gut wie nie vom so also das muss man ja mal sagen das ist ja eigentlich
nicht so gedacht
also normalerweise hast du das patchpedal und den switch und dann gehst du von dem switch
auf das patchpedal und von dem patchpedal überall hin unter anderem auch auf die geräte
im eigenen rack also sowas hier vorne machst du eigentlich gar nicht
gut in dem fall ist natürlich schwierig weil du willst ja auch ans usb drankommen aber
das ist ja auch keine
ist ja nicht für rack einsatz gebaut das ding
ok mehr sieht man nicht mehr klar oder
ok
die spannung hat sich in grenze gehalten dachte da kommt jetzt noch ein bisschen was
aber ist anscheinend nicht so
ist pl a das standard zeug das was bei so ziemlich jedem drucker dabei ist
der kleine schrank der war niedlich ja
ja da musste aber denke ich im normalen rack wenig gedanken machen 50 bis 60 grad so warm
wird doch da nichts am gehäuse
hast du ein nass ja aber kein nass was als nass verkauft wurde
ich habe eine x86 kiste hinten bei mir im serverraum stehen wo unter anderem halt bisschen
ein bisschen windows shares drauf laufen und noch andere zeug meine heimautomatisierung
läuft drauf
eigentlich läuft einiges drauf nass ist im prinzip ist ein stink normales stink normales
samba scherm für windows fertig das ist mein nass
also damit das mit damit das gehäuse 50 grad warm wird muss erstmal im raum 50 grad warm
sein
dass ich das so weit aufheizt 50 grad was bei mir im hinten in der in dem ding sicherlich
noch nie
da würde ich mir jetzt wenig gedanken zu machen das ist ok wenn jetzt da was wahnsinnig wenn
da jetzt was schweres drauf steht und das wirklich maximal maximal belastet wird ok
aber für so ein raspberry pi warum nicht
nfs nfs kannst du daheim noch gar nicht gebrauchen das sei denn du hast nur linux host meistens
will man doch auch windows host haben und dann bringt die nfs nix ich weiß man kriegt nfs
irgendwie zum laufen unter windows aber vergiss es
ganz ganz ganz ganz samba fertig aus ganz ganz easy und das einfachste
du hast den usb stick am router ja das sage ich ja auch oft die leute machen sich teilweise
viel zu verrückt und stellen sich viel zu krasse dinger daheim hin
ich rede jetzt nicht von kennt ihr noch das video von dem typ mit mit seinen drei kuppernetes
klassen daheim der verdient ja geld damit dass er übertriebenes zeug daheim hat aber
wenn es dir reicht wenn dir denn ordentliche usb stick am router reicht vielleicht machst
du nur ab und zu mal backups von von deinem
fotos die du auf dem iphone auf dem handy gemacht hast ja wenn das reicht ist das vollkommen
in ordnung der sinnvolle upgrade wäre vielleicht anstatt dem usb stick dort jetzt vielleicht
ein ssd dran oder sowas aber ansonsten warum nicht wenn du kriegst relativ günstig 128
gig usb sticks das reicht aber vielen sachen aus man muss es nicht total übertreiben es
ist immer sinnvoll mal das mindeste und naheliegendste und einfachste zu machen mit dem was man da
hat und dann gucken ob das überhaupt was ist so von der arbeitsweise was einem gefällt
und ob das nicht vielleicht sogar schon reicht ja der typ ich weiß nicht mal was es für
einen channel war der hatte nicht nur kubanetes am start er hatte irgendwie irgendwie zwei
rancher os dinge am start 2 kubanetes cluster zig dockercontainer nochmal extra auf irgendwas
anderem vm ware doppelt im cluster daheim da habe ich auch was zum teufel ist bei den
leuten los alter ich meine außer du möchtest unbedingt noch mehr strom verbrauchen für
nicht wirklich viel mehr vorteil value daheim technotim genau das total übertrieben gut
er verdient sein geld irgendwie damit dass es ein komisches setup daheim hat aber sinnvoll
ist es nicht ist halt ein hobby es ist ein doofes hobby für leute wie mich also wenn
du dich auf der arbeit schon mit so einem kram beschäftigt da will ich mich nicht zwangsläufig
noch mit dem gleichen müll daheim beschäftigen da beschäftigt mich lieber mit technik krams
der mich interessiert und irgendwelche komischen container sachen verwalten interessiert mich
nicht genug dass ich da bock darauf habe es daheim auch zu machen ja klar easy reicht
aber bei zwei kerne werden mir persönlich ein bisschen wenig aber wenn es reicht warum
nicht wie du am besten foto speichern archivieren kannst ehrlich gesagt ich bin nicht der große
fotomacher und auch nicht der große foto back aber aber ich habe letztens auf github
ein richtig cooles projekt gesehen für foto ex foto web explorer und backup wenn ich
jetzt bloß noch wüsste wie das heißt jetzt ab foto prism kann das sein weil das chat
weil der chat das gerade postet möglich möglich dass das das war ich bin mir da gar nicht
so sich ermöglicht ja es kann sein 22.000 sterne ist schon mal das das war es glaube
ich das war es glaube ich was ich gesehen habe ja das das habe ich gesehen nicht das
das meine ich hier das erinnert jetzt wo ich den namen sehe erinnert sich noch irgendjemand
an immer von der telekom hat man das anders geschrieben immer doch das war die telekom
was ab was whatsapp konkurrenz und wie erwarten wie zu erwarten war hat es nicht funktioniert
wir gucken jetzt gleich den konferenz talk weiter ich muss mal kurz gucken ob da drauf
geantwortet hat mit seinem truck ob es jetzt funktioniert ja dann nicht ja das habe ich
letztens gesehen das fand ich sagen wirklich nice aus also mit foto backups und sowas hat
es einen guten eindruck ich habe sie nicht ausprobiert fax im backend kann ich mir tatsächlich
vorstellen wenn die telekom 2015 oder so eine whatsapp konkurrenz macht in deutschland ist
es bestimmt noch fax ja ok dann gucken wir jetzt den konferenz talk von gestern weiter
weil der chat schon fragt für alle die sich gestern nicht die gestern nicht hier waren
wir haben gestern angefangen einen konferenz talk zu gucken von der wo war das ndc sitney
und wo sie alle auf dem kopf stehen also das ist eine dotnet entwickler konferenz und in
dem vortrag ging es um die geschichte von javascript um die geschichte von browsers um die geschichte
von web frameworks also wer jetzt die wer jetzt nicht dabei war ist wahrscheinlich
die nächsten 15 minuten etwas lost
wie sortiert ihr eure fotos automatisch gar nicht ok wo sind wir stehen geblieben bei
node.js sind wir stehen geblieben aber bis jetzt muss man schon sagen da ist wirklich
spannend gewesen wirklich nice der talk wir waren bei node.js dass er auf die blöde idee
gekommen ist javascript auf dem server zu machen genau und ich hatte gestern noch dazu
gesagt das war eine geniale und gleichzeitig total bescheuerte idee javascript auf dem
server zu machen dann hat im chat jemand gefragt ist node.js eine gute technologie da musste
ich sagen nein aber doch ist es das hat schon seinen anwendungszweck gerade dass die ganzen
frontend leute jetzt auch im backend rumwursten können dass frontend entwickler heute anwendung
erstellen können die des auf dem desktop laufen und mobile laufen und im browser laufen
also node.js hat schon gerade für das javascript ökosystem und auch für viele frontend entwickler
wirklich viel positives bewirkt ansonsten warum verwendet man noch node.js weil es gute
frage verwendet man jetzt wirklich gute antwort fällt mir darauf nicht ein großes großes
library beziehungsweise npm ökosystem also wer beispielsweise nicht weiß wie er testet
ob eine zahl gerade oder ungerade ist kann sehr beliebte npm packages benutzen wie zum
beispiel das da oder is even ja 429.000 downloads in der letzten woche anscheinend wissen javascript
programmierer nicht wie man zahlen auf gerade und ungerade checkt was ist denn der unterschied
von is odd zu is is odd
das ist ein meme package oder oder ich checks nicht ok ich muss nicht alles verstehen
du kannst coachen zwischen frontend und backend ja das tatsächlich ein vorteil so native web
geschichten wie craftql sind teilweise in wobei es das für viele andere sprachen auch gibt
sind teilweise in node einfacher möglich oder dieses dieses neue wo sie jetzt alle
sagen viel geiler als craftql ich hab schon den namen schon wieder vergessen weil es
gibt so viele neue sachen im javascript ökosystem wenn man sich da alles merkt platzt sein hirn
ich hab vergessen wie es heißt wie heißt das neueste neue hippe craftql was nicht mal
craftql ist für für node.js ja und auch viele server side rendering geschichten sind
auf node.js angewiesen weil wie sollte man also nicht server side rendering html sondern
komplettes hydration server side rendering also quasi mit state rüber schicken weil
wie sollst du javascript auf dem server ausführen ohne javascript zu haben irgendwie logisch
wie heißt denn das ding new da gab es doch letztens irgendwie sowas nein nein nein nein
nein trpc der chat weiß wieder bescheid trpc das ist jetzt der neueste shit die ganzen
coolen leute verwenden typescript und trpc ja und das geht alles um in node.js
google v8 engine just been released as well so he considered to be it to be obvious that
he should create a web server obviously java spent six months working on this and then
he brought it out in this conference in 2009 okay so javascript is everywhere by now and
this leads us to the next big step single page applications people were really pushing
past the limits of what you could do with jquery by now they were building big applications
and they were becoming a mess and we needed some discipline some way of structuring things
and a whole bunch of things came out at the same time und das haben wir gestern schon
gesehen egal die letzten die gucken wir jetzt auch noch nochmal noch mal das buch wird heute
noch gemeint ja das hatten wir gestern schon aber die zwei minuten halten wir noch durch
da wissen wir wo wir stehen geblieben sind gestern also mein lieblings framework hiervon
ist eindeutig sfeld view ist auch nice react habe ich noch nie was großartig mitgemacht
und angular ist eine runde kotzen ember hat mich damals so abgeschreckt dass ich nie wieder
was damit gemacht habe
da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern
das war doch angular gs nicht angular
becker bone
ohje jetzt kriegen wir backbone gezeigt ich habe damals ein bisschen rumgespielt mit backbone
ich muss sagen es hat mich hyper verwirrt die ganze sündags da war so viel nested nested
functions und nested javascript objects in functions nested objects in in objects functions
in functus war ganz wir also ich bin damit nicht klar gekommen aber ich war da ich war
vielleicht für frontend einfach zu nubisch zum damaligen zeitpunkt das ist to do application
ist ja wohl der klassiker das ist so das hello world der javascript frameworks guckt euch
das mal an der einstiegspunkt ist schon in den komischen verengene callback function monka
s alter also die also zu der zu der pre-essing await geschichte in javascript die haben da
ganz ganz wilde dinger getrieben
hatte letztens auf einer jobmesser ein interview mit einer hr-person die hat fütsch gesagt
ja komm es ist personal abteilungstyp gewesen mensch gewesen die müssen das nicht wissen
letztens im stream hatten wir doch jemand der hatte auch eine schöne aussprache von
view wie war das noch mal
wu wu oder wu gs das hört sich irgendwie so was japanischem an oder so wu gs das gibt
es auch das das das mit mit mit mit qi das war mein escher der typ der bei dem ich die
escher schuldung gemacht der q qi ausgesprochen hat ich mein besser besser als qi qi
so wir haben hier ein model wir haben hier ein view und wir haben hier ein controllerisch
kind of thing it's always a bit ambiguous in an mvc like what is the controller is it
a view model no one really cares the point is that we've got model view separation that's
the key thing and in this case we've got a model for to do's we've got a model ok das
ist jetzt noch halbwegs lesbar aber leute das ist leute das ist ich sehe da jetzt schon
ganz mehr callbacks als mein hirn handeln kann der ganze einstiegspunkt ist schon ein
callback
ich mein wenn sich nicht dran erinnert js callback hell
guckt euch das an das war eine zeitlang normal das java script so ausgeschaut hat
mittlerweile mit essig und weid hält sich allerdings glücklicherweise glücklicherweise
in grenzen problematisch ist nur dass halt viele browser
apis immer noch nicht essig weid sind weil sie halt so alt sind und der neue noch nicht
angepasst wurden und überhaupt aber immerhin gibt es jetzt im browser glaube ich seit 30
jahren zum ersten mal eine halbwegs gescheite date time api
based on what's in the model such as how many tasks are remaining and to render that in
the ui we've it's using underscore templating underscore is a javascript library created
by jeremy ashkenaz
und underscore gab's ja auch noch wie wie hieß noch mal die konkurrenz zu anders gott
js gab's dann auch noch
low dash und underscore braucht man heutzutage eigentlich nicht mehr
nee du brauchst weder node js weder moment js noch time functions mittlerweile gibt's
wohl eine eingebaute date api in neueren browser version die ganz gut ist
was hat low dash gemacht ist gleiche wie underscore
das sind utility libraries da konntest du zum beispiel arrays sortieren arrays filtern
was weiß ich
die sachen zu großschreibung kleinschreibung so zeug ja war ganz war ganz nützlich zu
zeiten wo vieles in javascript noch nicht drinne war
ich kanns euch doch mal zeigen gett hab underscore js mit immer noch geupdated gibt's nix
also diese webseite mein hirn platzt alter
was ist das
liegt das am dark reader
teilweise da konntest du solche dinge machen guck irgendwie arrays filtern collections
zählen partition to array also bisschen wie link ein bisschen wie link in c sharp nur
nur für javascript
aber vieles ist ja heute in javascript standardmäßig schon dabei
deswegen braucht man das gar nicht mehr oder ist es nicht alles dabei aber genug dass man
das nicht mal braucht
was war atom nicht in kofi script
wer das nicht kennt kofi script war eine programmiersprache die nach javascript transpiled hat um in javascript
wörtern zu bleiben also du hast kofi script programmiert und du hast auf den build button
gedrückt und unten drunter kam javascript raus aber du konntest halt javascript programmieren
ohne javascript zu programmieren
so ähnlich wie typescript naja nee sieht anders aus
kofi script war viel mehr ruby kofi script war sehr ruby style
jetzt hab kofi script
guckts da so aus
ah geiles beispiel null hier
sieht so aus
ja das ist das sieht ein bisschen ruby style aus
ruby
aber benutzt eigentlich keiner mehr heutzutage
und ohne types natürlich
didn't
Pain's Champ Webpack
Moment, ich kann den Anblick nicht ertragen, Sekunde Leute, muss das da drüber lassen
People by now needed a new language to try and allow them to do this at a higher scale. TypeScript is the one that's ultimately won. The idea of compiling stuff to JavaScript wasn't new with TypeScript, so I just mentioned Ashkenaz and his CoffeeScript language, that was probably the first one that really got a lot of attention. And TypeScript followed on by that, by adding a full proper type system. Obviously you will know about...
But I don't know, until today it hasn't completely... I don't know, it hasn't completely knocked me over with TypeScript.
When I'm compiling something, I'm still using normal JavaScript. I don't want to have an in-between step. But I'm not going to make super big business applications either.
TS is very similar to C Sharp.
I don't know. It's got some similarities, like the generics and stuff.
It's a bit similar. Yes, I mean, it's pretty much the same as the C Sharp inventor is the TypeScript inventor. But I've recently read that the TypeScript, that the type system of TypeScript is totally turned off. I think someone programmed a regex engine in TypeScript templates. I think I read that somewhere recently.
Oh ne, wir sind uns ja einig. Was geht, wird gemacht.
...solving real problems for developers. And going with the fact that this is compiled and people are doing so much of this, we now need compilation and bundling systems. So Webpack came along to fill that need.
Boah, Webpack. I know that's not really specific to front-end web development, but it just gives you a hint of how much stuff web developers were being expected to know about by now. It's not just front-end dev and back-end and styling and build systems and stuff.
Ich hasse auch Webpack, Alter. Das ist ein ganz schreckliches Ding. Ja, da ist man wie deutlich lieber. Da funktionieren die Sachen meistens einfach direkt.
But one other thing came out around this time, which is pretty important, and that is WebAssembly. So this is the thing that finally separates us from that design directive that Andreessen gave in the beginning, saying you have to be able to just type the script in.
...so the idea at this point is there are lots of other great programming languages out there. We want to run them in the browser...
Man kann es jetzt quasi WebAssembly auf Serverseite ausführen.
Ich verstehe nicht so genau, ich habe keine Ahnung warum Leute.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich mein, warum kann man das Programm nicht einfach direkt als x86 executable bauen,
wenn man es als WebAssembly baut.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht, vielleicht halt an Stellen, wo auch drumherum noch JavaScript eingesetzt
wird.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung.
Ich muss mir das mal angucken, also ich sehe aktuell den Sinn nicht so wirklich drin.
Ja, vielleicht aus Portabilitätsgründen, wenn du irgendwas hast, was du als Webanwendung
laufen lässt mit ein bisschen WebAssembly, dann musst du es nicht komplett irgendwie
umstricken, dann für, für, auf, auf, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht.
Es ist ähnlich zu Doc, was, was hat WebAssembly denn schon mit Docker zu tun?
Das sind doch zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Das eine ist quasi so eine, so eine Mini-VM, äh, nicht VM in Form von virtuellem Computer,
sondern so Mini, Mini-Runtime Sandbox.
Und das andere ist ein Frontend für die Linux-Container-Funktionalität, kernel-Container-Funktionalität.
Die WebAssembly-Runtime lassen sich halt kontenerisieren, du kannst so gut wie alles kontenerisieren.
Warum solltest du beispielsweise, also wenn du das Programm übersetzt in WebAssembly
und im Container laufen lässt, kannst du doch genauso gut das Programm gleich in x86 übersetzen
und auch im Container laufen lassen, also wo ist der Unterschied?
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht, du kannst alles im Container laufen lassen.
Wie gesagt, Container existieren ja in der Form eh nicht, das ist ja, ich, das Wort
ist irgendwie immer noch fail, aber da muss ich mich dran gewöhnen, weil das wird, wird
es weiterhin so geben und werden auch weiterhin so benutzen.
Container hört sich viel zu sehr nach irgendwie Richtung VM an, so ein gestarteter Prozess
im Container ist einfach ein stinknormal gestarteter Prozess mit ein paar Kleinigkeiten noch drum
herum, aber da ist nichts irgendwie groß anders dran.
Ja also ich sehe jetzt überhaupt keine Konkurrenz zu Docker in WebAssembly, also das eine sind
noch zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe, mal gucken, mal gucken was da rauskommt,
wir gucken jetzt den Talk fertig.
Gut, der Kerl arbeitet für Microsoft, selbstverständlich war da Microsoft auch dran beteiligt, was
soll er sonst sagen?
Oh nee, jetzt kommt Blazer, jetzt kommt Blazer.
Eine der Sachen aus diesem Kern.NET umfällt, den ich nichts abgewinnen kann, ich bin.NET
Fanboy, aber es gibt zwei Sachen, die mag ich nicht, das ist, oder was heißt die mag
ich nicht, die sind mir wurscht, also die benutze ich nicht, das eine ist Blazer und
das andere ist Maui, Auxemirin vorher, Blazer ist alles andere als Blazingly Fast.
Blazer ist Blazingly, Slow ergibt keinen Sinn, keine Ahnung, Blazingly rückwärts schnell,
also Blazer ist nicht schnell und Blazer ist richtig fett, als es rausgekommen ist, mittlerweile
haben sie es wahrscheinlich kleiner, als es rausgekommen ist, haben die komplettes Mono,
musstest du komplettes Mono Runtime runterladen und die war glaube ich irgendwie 12 MB oder
so, da musst du erstmal 12 MB laden, dass das funktioniert hat und das blöde daran
ist, dass die, das reicht ja noch nicht mal, also du musst ja dann quasi noch dein C Sharp
irgendwie ausführen da drin, also der Unterschied zu einem Rust Programm ist, oder zu einem
C Programm, wenn ich das kompiliere, kommt WebAssembly raus, wenn ich C Sharp im Browser
laufen lassen will, dann brauche ich eine nach WebAssembly kompilierte.NET Runtime,
die dann aber selbst wiederum erstmal C Sharp ausführen muss beziehungsweise IL kompilieren
oder was es da auch immer mitmacht, aber man muss sagen, das ist alles nicht so der Weisheitsletzter
Schluss bis jetzt.
Es gibt auch Server-Site, Server-Site Blazer, da geht das ganze über WebSockets, da wieder
was ganz was anderes, egal, fertig gucken, das sieht halt immer noch so aus.
Das sieht auch immer noch genauso aus, ja ich sage, das sieht heute immer noch so aus.
Zusätzlich gibt es noch keine WebAssembly API für DOM Manipulation, ja das stimmt,
aber dafür kannst du ja JavaScript verwenden, ich finde das ergänzt sich ganz gut, erinnert
ihr euch noch an das Projekt im Stream, wo wir FFmpeg cross-compiled haben zu WebAssembly
und dann mit C++ ein Videoplayer gebaut haben, der sich das Video vom Server gestreamt hat
und das war abgedrehter Shit, oder?
Das war was, das müsste ich eigentlich mal auf GitHub hochladen, ich glaube das ist was,
was viele Leute interessieren könnte, sehr wild war das, sehr wild, aber es hat funktioniert,
das lief richtig gut, muss man sagen, das lief wirklich performant, wir haben das ausgeführt
in einer VM, also in meiner, ja C++ war für WebAssembly in dem Fall ganz gut, das lief
in einer VM und wir haben es geschafft 1080p Videos mit 30 FPS abzuspielen, decoded über
FFmpeg in WebAssembly, ja das war wirklich nicht schlecht, konntest nichts sagen, war
echt sehr, sehr nice.
Wir haben schon richtig viel Zeug gemacht im Stream, oder?
Wir haben alles schon mal irgendwie gemacht, WebAssembly im Browser, Microcontroller Zeug,
Elektronikram gebastelt, Web Anwendung, Server Anwendung, Kommando Zeilen, wir haben alles
schon gemacht.
Cobol, wir haben sogar Cobol gehört, Cobol gemacht, also nur worauf ich, nur worauf
ich eigentlich zeige euch das, wir können das neue Archiv verwenden, hier war das dev.archiv,
Achtung, WebAssembly, nicht nach WebAs, Rust WebAssembly, ne das hat nicht funktioniert,
WebAssembly MonkaS, WebAssembly FFmpeg, hier guckt, Video läuft im Browser, Video läuft
im Browser, 720p, 60, ach Moment, das war nicht der letzte Stream, hier haben wir das
ja noch hochgeladen von Han, wir hatten danach einen Stream, das ist wahrscheinlich der hier,
wir hatten danach einen Stream, da haben wir das vom Server gestreamt, das Video, FFmpeg
Shit, Leute, das war grausam, ja genau, hier, guck mal, wir spielen im Browser ein Mpeg2
Video ab, decoded, gestreamt vom Server, decoded FFmpeg WebAssembly, das ist richtig, richtig
bigbrain, ich sag mal, rückblickend gesprochen, glaube ich, war das der bigbrainigste Stream,
den ich je gemacht hab, oder was sagt ihr, für alle, die sich noch dran erinnern können,
das lief richtig gut, das ist, also man muss jetzt nochmal euch erklären, also damit kann
ein Browser Video Formate abspielen, die er normalerweise nicht abspielen kann, weil
er die Videos selbst decoden kann, das war richtig nice, das Video, was ihr gerade seht,
ist ein Format, was der Browser normalerweise nicht abspielen kann, das heißt, du brauchst
normalerweise irgendwo im Mpeg etwas, was dir den Kram transcoded, und so kann es der
Browser selbst machen.
So, fertig, guck mal.
Das war aber nicht beim Blazer, was sie released haben, das Blazer, was ich ausprobiert hab
mit Mono, war irgendwie 12MB, da hab ich meine Zweifel, das müssen wir mal ausprobieren,
wie groß das aktuell ist, also ich bin mir sehr, sehr sicher, dass Mono bestimmt um
die, vielleicht nicht 12, aber um die 10MB war, als ich das ausprobiert hab, und es
war auch nicht 52KB, garantiert nicht, achso, ja, das haben die dann ersetzt mit Mono und
dann war es 8MB oder 10MB groß oder 12MB groß, um die 10MB.
Okay, so, that almost brings us to the current day, and I'm not gonna try and interpret what's
happened for the last couple of years, because I think like the dust hasn't really settled
on history yet, we don't know what's gonna be important in the long run, but we can start
to think a little bit about where we might be heading in the future, what are some of
the big trends?
Okay, lasst mal überlegen, was sind big trends im Frontend?
Die ganzen Metaframeworks sind voll angesagt aktuell, und so Sachen wie Quick und Astro
und so Zeug, wie heißt das jetzt, Partial Hydration und Massive Buzzwords, und ansonsten
fällt mir schwer, was zu sagen.
CSS-Nesting, das ist das, was du letztens angesprochen hast, gell, Breselif, das klass,
dass du weinest.
Oh, das wäre natürlich sehr nice, TypeScript direkt im Browser ohne irgendwelche komischen
Compile-Steps, und CSS-Nesting wäre auch sehr, sehr nice, dann bräuchte man weniger SAS,
bzw. ich verwende SAS ja so gut wie nie, aber für manche Sachen ist es nice, und das bräuchte
man dann immer weniger, weil ich bin der Meinung, dass wahrscheinlich bläst er da ins gleiche
Horn, umso weniger Zwischenschritte du einziehen musst, umso besser, also wenn du einen Compile-Step
mit TypeScript weniger hast, ist es gut, wenn du irgendwelche CSS-Helper-Dinger weniger
hast, weil es der Browser kann, ist es gut, wenn du keinen Load-Dash und Underscore mehr
brauchst, weil JavaScript es eingebaut hat, ist es gut, also umso weniger Zwischenschritte
man braucht, umso besser, weil irgendwie blickst du wirklich nimmer durch.
Ne, kein Overwatch 2 gerade.
Besseren Variablen-Support, Variables, Metaframeworks, ja, das ist das, was mir auch eingefallen
wäre, genau, Astro, SvelteKit, ja, SvelteKit ist halt hoge.
SvelteKit ist nice, und ich habe SvelteKit mir tatsächlich nur angeguckt, weil irgendjemand
im Stream gesagt hat, lass uns das mal angucken, und ich finde es wirklich top.
Der Chat war es, ja.
Cloud Edge Delivery, da habe ich in letzter Zeit tatsächlich relativ viel drüber gehört,
auf Web Talks und Sachen gesehen dazu, ja, Edge Delivery, beziehungsweise Sachen halt
möglichst nah an dem ausführen oder ausliefern, wo es gebraucht wäre, das ist ein gewisser
Trend, ja, auch im Hinblick auf Cloud Functions, es geht ja auch ein bisschen dahin, dass man
seine Cloud Functions eben möglichst nah da laufen lässt, wo denn derjenige sitzt, der
das empfangen will, mit allem geht das natürlich nicht, ja, Datenbank ist halt nix an der Edge,
ja, aber können wir vorstellen, dass das weiterhin so im Trend bleiben wird, weil ganz ehrlich,
Response Time ist das wichtigste für eine Webseite, annehmbare Response Time, also man
kann sich jetzt sicherlich drüber streiten, ob es einen Unterschied macht, ob es, keine
Ahnung, 30 oder 20 Millisekunden sind, aber in dem Bereich bewegen wir uns ja heute gar
nicht, heute braucht es bis eine Webseite auf ist, wahrscheinlich im Durchschnitt, weiß
ich nicht, 400 bis 500 Millisekunden bis es wirklich ordentlich da ist, schnelle Webseiten
sind natürlich, also leichtgewichtige Webseiten sind natürlich schneller, unter 100 Millisekunden
am Start, aber größere Webseiten, also eine Webseite, die mir wirklich als sehr schnell
in Erinnerung geblieben ist, ist Patreon, ich weiß nicht, was die machen, das ist aber
halt auch mehr oder weniger nur statischer Content, Patreon ist wirklich schnell, wenn
man, das machen wir mal einen Darkreader aus, das ist lahm as fuck, machen wir mal einen
Creator auf oder so, also Patreon hatte ich immer, jetzt kann mir hier gar nichts klicken,
aber Patreon hatte ich immer als Seite in Erinnerung, die wirklich schnell war, aber
Millisekunden, es kommt da wirklich auf Millisekunden an, es gibt doch diese Studie für Webshops
und also generell für Webseiten, das quasi, das schlimmste ist, was dir passieren kann,
dass quasi die Leute schon abspringen vom Kaufen oder vom Geld ausgeben bei deinem Service
bzw. bei deiner Webseite, noch bevor sie überhaupt auf deiner Webseite gewesen sind und das liegt
halt einfach an Ladezeiten, Webseiten müssen schnell sein, wir hatten die letzten Jahre
über eher den gegenläufigen Trend, soviel Single Page Applications und hast du nicht
gesehen, dass die Ladezeiten halt relativ langsam gewesen sind, dafür hatten wir auch
richtig viel Funktionalitätsboom, was Webseiten heute, also was Webanwendungen, Webseiten
sind es ja gar nicht mehr, was Webseiten heute können, ist natürlich nicht mit dem zu vergleichen,
was Webseiten früher konnten, also viel, viel mehr, deswegen sind es keine Webseiten,
es sind wirklich Webanwendungen heute, das haben wir zum größten Teil tatsächlich Single
Page bzw.
die kleinzeitigen Anwendungen zu verdanken, der Trend geht, ich weiß nicht, ob der Trend
zu Server-Side-Rendering zurückgeht, der Trend geht auf jeden Fall zurück zu Teilweise Server-Side-Rendering,
allerdings Server-Side-Rendering und dann auf dem Client weitermachen mit interaktiven
Sachen.
Oder aber in so Sachen wie was Astro macht, dass nur noch Teile der Seite überhaupt dynamisch
sind oder was was Quick macht, was quasi den kompletten State irgendwie einfriert und dann
auf den Client lädt, was natürlich praktisch ist, das funktioniert besser für Suchmaschinen,
wenn du Server-seitig was rendest von der Seite, viel, viel besser, also du kannst Single
Page Applikate, kannst du gar nicht so schnell durchsuchen, gescheit finden in Google oder
in irgendeiner anderen Suchmaschine und es lädt schneller und du kannst das zum Teil
natürlich dann auch von der Edge ausliefern, also der Trend wird auf jeden Fall weitergehen.
Gipfelkrieger, naja, weil es mich interessiert, das ist doch auch das, was ich im Steam öfters
mache, es schad' nix, wenn man ein bisschen Ahnung hat von allen möglichen Sachen, natürlich
wird man sich nicht wirklich tiefgreifen in allem auskennen, aber so ein bisschen Überblick,
es ist doch so wie es ist, man muss Ahnung haben, wenn man keine Ahnung hat, muss man
sich auch nicht wundern, wenn man nicht gescheit bezahlt wird bzw. einen keiner haben will für
seine Vorstellung, die man hat.
Bei mir ist es halt so, für die Sachen wo ich mich interessiere, interessiere ich mich
kurzfristig auch dann wirklich sehr ausführlich und lerne die Sachen relativ schnell, also
wenn mich irgendwas interessiert, gerade weil ich irgendein Problem habe, was ich lösen
will, dann sitze ich da Wochen bis zwei, drei Monate dran und mache fast nichts anderes
als mich damit zu beschäftigen und dementsprechend bin ich nach zwei, drei Monaten dann meistens
auch relativ fit, was das angeht, gut dann mache ich wieder was anderes, aber einiges
bleibt trotzdem hängen, zum Beispiel diese ganze FFmpeg WebAssembly Geschichte, da ist
auch ein bisschen was hängen geblieben, das heißt brauche ich morgen nicht auf der Arbeit,
aber vieles von dem was ich mir angeguckt habe, weil es mich interessiert hat, hat sich
auch auf der Arbeit gelohnt, also Ahnung zu haben ist nie verkehrt, dementsprechend weiß
ich natürlich auch, dass es ganz viel gibt, wo ich keinen Plan von habe, muss man sich
auch eingestehen, aber jetzt kriegen wir eine Runde SvelteKit gezeigt, bestes Framework.
Wenn wir in der Runde schauen, dann sehen wir, dass es nur eine statische Message ist, nicht viel zu sehen.
Wenn wir in der Runde schauen, haben wir nicht viel, aber es lässt uns Svelte, den Klienten
der Spar-Framenwerk, anbieten, um eine interaktive UI zu bauen, wir können sehen, dass die
Initial-Runde nur statische Content ist.
Wenn ich starte, zu editieren, dann sehen wir, wie das Hot Reload-Stuff funktioniert, ich
habe jetzt nicht auf Save gedrückt, das heißt Hot Module Replacement, das heißt es korrekterweise,
denn es weiß über meine Idee, und ich könnte auch ein bisschen Style machen, aber ich habe
nicht auf Save gedrückt, ich habe nur ein bisschen Kode gemacht, und es weiß, wie man
das machen kann.
Früher hast du sowas mit Reload-Plugins gemacht im Browser, die haben ja immer die komplette
Seite neu geladen, und Webpack hat sowas auch probiert, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch
war, aber bei mir hat Webpack öfters mal gefehlt, Seiten zu Hot zu Reloaden, Webpack, nicht Webkit,
habe ich Webkit gesagt, Webpack, Counter, ich kann mir nichts besseres auf einer Webseite
vorstellen als Counter, ich bin nicht mehr auf dem aktuellen Standleute, was Weltkit
angeht, das ist die neue Benamung, oder, die neue Ordnerstruktur und die neue Benamung,
die gibt es noch nicht so lange, seitdem habe ich noch nichts mit Welt wieder gemacht.
Bekommt.net Maury in Visual Studio mittlerweile auch recht gut hin, okay, nervig ist eine Sache,
die Maury hinbekommt.
Also ich finde Svelte wirklich sehr elegant was das angeht, manchmal ist mir Svelte ein
bisschen zu magic, manchmal weißt du nicht was Reactive ist und was nicht, ja alles ist
Reactive, bis es dann auf einmal nicht aktualisiert.
Jetzt, bevor der mit Server-Site Sachen anfängt, jetzt sind wir bei dem Punkt wieder, warum
Node.js doch eine wichtige Technologie in der heutigen Zeit ist, das würde ohne Node.js
alles, was man hier sieht, nicht funktionieren, könnt ihr vergessen, also das ganze Build-System
davon würde ja schon mal nicht funktionieren, aber spätestens wenn er anfängt mit irgendwelchen
Server-Sites, aktiven Server-Sites, das ist alles Node.js, das würde ohne nicht gehen,
da kann auch Dings hier, wie heißt, Bun und Deno und Gedöns einpacken, an der Verbreitung
von Node kommt da nichts vorbei, kannst du nachher einen Streamer rein, wen denn, Indie-Fox,
beide gibt's gar nicht mehr auf Twitch, oder?
Wie soll ich denn reden?
Okay, mal gucken, oh jetzt, jetzt kommt Sixer-Time.
Guck, und das läuft selbstverständlich alles mit Node im Backend.
Das ist sogar total geil.
right now with server-side rendering that's pretty good it can work without script but you know this browser does in fact support javascript so could we perhaps even have some kind of hybrid where it would support server-side execution or client-side execution and dynamically use both depending on what's best well we can so i can go to this form here and i can add this magic little use enhance on it which needs to import a certain
aber das habe ich noch nie verwendet ich habe noch nie meine form enthans
ne pap braucht man immer noch
jeder 0-15-host da kann pap ausführen node.js nicht so sehr
oh es ist enhanced
ah ok es real...
ach so das update in den state auf dem server rendert aber weiter client-seitig parallel dazu oh das ist das ist next level 5-head shit da kannst du da kannst du quasi state server-seitig
da brauchst du das ist ja quasi so eine art persistente session oder sowas in der richtung dann schwer schwer zu zu sagen das das hört sich erstmal nützlich an
through an http post but it's getting the result back and doing client-side rendering because this browser supports it but if i was a crawler it would be doing server-side rendering so that is pretty nice way of getting the nice of both so the point i'm making here is that by having this meta framework we can have new types of features now i know if you're a dotnet developer you might think hang on i think i've already got a meta framework it's like i've already got this one thing that does
server and client and id and build and stuff that's kind of true but the fact that these ideas are coming into javascript now is inspiring a lot of new innovation in terms of those features which the whole web community can benefit from so i think that's pretty exciting stuff so that's all we've got time to talk about this morning i think
super also ich muss mal gucken was er sonst noch so für talks gegeben hat ich glaube da hat jede menge blazer talks das interessiert mich jetzt überhaupt nicht aber der talk war wirklich gut der aber sehr spannend schon das fireship video geschaut nee jetzt ich
ich hab jetzt auch keine zeit mehr
großartig was anzugucken
indy fox ist jetzt auf anderen seiten unterwegs
so so
keine pool streams mehr
ich hab ja eh leute
ich weiß nicht ob ich das schonmal erzählt habe
ich habe eh angst vor pool streams
vor pool streams
angst ist das falsche wort
ich habe eh
ich verbinde das mit
kindheitserinnerungen
die
ja ok das muss ich euch jetzt erzählen
also
passt mal auf
jetzt kommt's
wisst ihr was das erste
das erste mal in meinem leben war wo ich
eine frau bzw. ein mädchen
nackig gesehen hab
hab ich euch glaub ich noch nie erzählt
selbstverständlich das erste und einzige mal wir sind hier
informatiker stream da gibt so was nicht
aber ne wisst ihr
spaßvoll sein das ist das erste weiß ich ob ich das
mal jemals erzählt hab das erste mal wo ich ein
mädchen nackig gesehen hab
das hat nämlich was mit pools zu tun
nicht fkk
baggersee ja ok
da vielleicht auch aber da hat es mich nicht großartig
interessiert also pass mal auf
ich war im urlaub mit meiner
mutter ihrem kerl
einer freund ne
ne stimmt grad nicht mit ihrem kerl
meiner mutter einer freundin von ihr
und die tochter von
der freundin so ich war da so
keine ahnung
oder so glaube ich
irgendwie in dem dreh
vielleicht noch ein bisschen jünger weiß ich
und die dürfte irgendwie so
15 16 gewesen sein in dem dreh
die war ein bisschen älter
und middels in dem alter
ist das eh was
anders die sind da eh schon ein bisschen
weiter zumindest
wir waren da im hotel
und uns draußen
gab es halt direkt
von diesem bungalow gab es halt
einen pool wobei das kein pool war
das war so ein langes also das das war
so ne so ne so ne wasserstraße
quasi die ging so durch das
ganze grundstück von diesem
von diesem hotel
und
da kommt man dann quasi
direkt direkt ins wasser
vom bungalow reinspringen und wieder raus
zumindest ich
ich steh da so abends
auf dem auf der terrasse von
diesem bungalow ja
und auf einmal steigt die naggisch
aus diesem pool raus
und läuft auf die terrasse
und ich war
komplett
monac
s alter
ne ne
ohne scheiß daran habe ich überhaupt nicht
gedacht damals
damals habe ich überhaupt nicht da als quatsch an sowas
habe ich da nicht dran gedacht es war
mir nur äußerst unangenehm
damals es war mir äußerst
unangenehm das weiß ich noch
ich wusste damals gar nicht was ich machen soll
ich hab dann da zwar hingeguckt
aber
hab mir eigentlich gedacht das gehört sich jetzt ja nicht da so
hin zu klotzen und hab dann wieder weg geguckt
und Leute ich hab
das hat mich das hat mich fertig gemacht damals
das weiß ich noch
hab ich überhaupt nicht mit gerechnet
da eine naggisch vor dir alter
das hat mich das hat mich sehr das hat mich
sehr verwirrt damals ja
und deswegen
halt
auch wenn es nur halbnaggische medels im pool
sind erinnert mich das immer sofort an
diese geschichte
daniel lull
dankeschön für 40 monate subscription
ja
das war das erste mal wo ich
quatsch das war in keinster
weise in dieser richtung
die ist da einfach nur rausgelaufen
wahrscheinlich wollte jemand gucken wie ich reagiere oder so
ich weiß nicht aber es hat mich damals
mit 12 wirklich äußerst verwirrt
das
war
also war was ja
daran
an diese sache erinnere mich die ganzen hot hub streams
immer
so jetzt hab ich euch das auch mal erzählt
alles klar
so leute wir sehen uns ich geh jetzt pennen
bis morgen machts gut
tschüss